Well, what's this satellite dish doing
on the screen over here?
Mankind has been probing space for quite
a while.
In 1983, Newsweek reported the real hope
is not just to intercept an alien
weather report,
but to hear a message intended for Earth
or for the universe at large.
And in 1983, US News and World Report
wrote, "If anyone is trying to get in
touch with us, we're ready to listen.
Hello, anybody out there?"
Very interesting.
The first cosmonaut that went up into
space said there wasn't any God there.
We never saw him once. Well, you can
expect that.
Why are we so cut off? Why are we so cut
off? The Bible tells us we are cut off
because of
sin.
And I heard the voice of the Lord God
walking in the garden in the cool of the
day, and Adam and his wife hid
themselves from the presence of the Lord
God amongst the trees of the garden.
Genesis 3:8. So, they hid themselves. We
hid ourselves.
But your iniquities have separated
between you and your God, and your sins
have hid his face from you that he will
not hear. Isaiah 59:2.
So, mankind cannot see God at the moment
because God and sin are incompatible.
Thank God,
God had a plan, and Jesus came to
reconnect us to heaven.
Even these may forget, but I will not
forget you. Behold, I have inscribed you
on the palms of my hand. Isaiah 49:15
and 16. If mankind wanted to,
they wouldn't have to go floating up
there and say, "You, anybody out there?"
They can just read their Bible and look
at history, and they will know there is
someone out there who cares enough.
And he came to this Earth, and he
lived down here,
and he suffered for us, and he died for
us. Amos 3:7. Surely the Lord God will
do nothing
but he revealeth his secret unto his
servants the prophets.
God has always spoken to this Earth
through his prophets.
And sometimes there was nobody left but
his prophets. And sometimes the world
was so iniquitous there weren't even
prophets speaking anymore.
But the world didn't like the prophets.
They preferred to say, "You,
anybody out there?"
They don't like listening to the
prophets.
2 Peter 1:21. For the prophecy came not
in old time by the will of man,
but holy men of God spoke as they were
moved by the Holy Ghost. So, the Bible
clearly says that prophecy is something
that comes from God. God communicating
his will to man. And we don't want that.
God actually wrote with his finger on
stone and said, "This is my will. If you
adhere to this, we'll talk." Nope, we
don't want that. We'll make our own.
If there be a prophet amongst you, I the
Lord will make myself known unto him in
a vision, and I will speak unto him in a
dream. Numbers 12:6.
So, it's very important that we
understand how does God communicate
through his prophets, and how do we know
whether someone is a prophet or a liar?
So, we have to follow the biblical
criteria. So, if there's a prophet,
God will speak to him in a vision and in
a dream. So, here comes a guy and says,
"I've had a vision. I've had a dream."
How do you know it's from God or whether
it's from another source?
God has spoken by the mouth of all his
holy prophets since the world began.
Acts 3:21. Man has really no excuse.
Shouldn't be cut off.
And of course, the greatest message of
all time came in Jesus Christ.
And the message was in John 12:32. "And
I, if I am lifted up from Earth, I will
draw all to myself."
This is the greatest message of all
time.
Despise not prophesying. Prove all
things. Hold fast that which is good. 1
Thessalonians 5:20-21.
Today, people despise prophecy because
there's so much false prophecy. How do
you know which is true and which is
false? But the Bible says don't despise
it. Prove it. Check it out. If it's from
God, hold on to it. If not, get rid of
it.
How do I know if it's from God or
whether it's not from God?
Obviously, God can't let us dangle
there. Well, I feel it's from God or
whatever. No, no, no.
You have to know whether it's from God.
2 Chronicles 20:20. Believe in the Lord
God,
your God, so shall you be established.
Believe his prophets,
so shall you prosper. Important that we
listen to the prophets because they warn
us
of the hazards along the path. They may
not speak out of harmony with God's
word, but they tell us where we are in
the stream of time. Matthew 24:24. There
shall arise false Christs, false
prophets, shall show great signs and
wonders in so much that were possible,
they shall deceive the very elect. Big
problem.
So now,
how do I know which one is from God and
which one is not? So, I mustn't despise
prophecy. I must prove it. I must hold
on to that which is good, but I must
watch out for false prophets. That's
what the Bible says.
Beloved, believe not every spirit, but
try the spirits whether they are of God
because many false prophets are gone out
into the world. This is a big job.
The Lord is not asking from us a small
thing here. This is a big job. Huge
numbers of prophets out there.
Which one is from God and which one is
not?
Try them.
Check them out. Is it from God or is it
not?
And thou child shall be called the
prophet of the highest, and thou shalt
go before the face of the Lord to
prepare his way. So, a prophet
talks about the coming of the Lord.
Prepare yourselves for the coming of the
Lord. Give knowledge of salvation. A
true prophet will tell you how you can
be saved unto his people by the
remission of their sins.
So, a true prophet will not say
there is nothing worse that can be done
than to talk of the lost sinful
condition of man.
True prophets won't say that.
True prophets will say
we are all sinners, and we need
redemption in Jesus Christ.
Through the tender mercy of our God,
whereby the day spring from on high has
visited us to give light to them that
sit in darkness
and in the shadow of death to guide our
feet in the way of peace. That's what a
prophet should do. But a preacher can do
that, too. It doesn't have to be a
prophet to do that. Anybody can do that
as long as he sticks to the word of God.
But a prophet, even more so. A prophet
must be in line with the biblical
teachings.
So, how do we test the prophets? How do
we know someone is a prophet of God or
is not a prophet of God? Well, let's
look at the criteria that the Bible
gives. A true prophet's message must be
in harmony with the word of God
and the law of God.
To the law and to the testimony, if they
speak not according to this word, it is
because there is no light in them. The
law is the first five books of the
Bible, the Torah, which also contains
the 10 Commandments. And the testimony
is everything that the prophets have
said in harmony with the Torah.
Isaiah 8:20. The law is no more.
Her prophets also finds no visions from
the Lord. Lamentations 2:9. God is not
inconsistent.
You cannot be out of harmony with God's
word, and then expect God to speak to
you.
So, they have to keep the law of God.
They have to be in harmony with the law
of God, and they have to speak according
to the Bible
and be obedient to its precepts. A true
prophet. Well, that cuts out a lot of
them. There goes Nostradamus. Poof,
gone.
All his visions he got under drugs. Is
that in harmony with the Bible?
Don't think so.
Two. A true prophet's predictions must
come true.
Deuteronomy 18:22, when a prophet
speaketh in the name of the Lord, if the
thing follow not nor come to pass, that
is the thing which the Lord has not
spoken, but the prophet has spoken
presumptuously, thou shalt not be afraid
of him.
So, every prophet that tells you
which horse is going to win the next
race, and he is happens to be right, is
from God? Yes or no?
No. Obviously, this one must be
qualified with what?
With all the others.
So, everything must apply to the
prophet, not just this one, because a
false prophet can also get things right.
And then the worst of it is
that a true prophet
can actually say something that doesn't
come to pass and still be a true
prophet.
Do we have examples in the Bible?
Jonah? What did Jonah say?
Nineveh is going to be destroyed. 40
days and it's all over.
Was Nineveh destroyed?
No.
And Jonah knew it, and he was totally
freaked out because he knew
that this might not come to pass. Why
not?
Because prophecy is conditional.
You see, the prophet had told them, you
are sinners, and God is going to destroy
this place. What did the Ninevites do?
They repented in sackcloth and ashes,
and Jonah went and
grumbled about this issue because he
knew that now it could be construed that
he was a false prophet. See?
So, careful how you deal with a true
prophet's predictions must come true.
Yes, a prophet must be
trustworthy, what he says must come
true, but we mustn't forget the
conditionalist aspect, and we mustn't
forget all the other aspects associated
with it as well. So, he must speak in
accordance with the law, he must also
be truthful. Thirdly, a true prophet
edifies God's people.
But he that prophesieth speaketh unto
men to edification and exhortation and
comfort. He that prophesieth edifieth
the church.
You see, God chooses prophets out of his
church. When Saul was called
and became Paul thereafter, he was sent
to
the church.
He was sent to the church to find out
what he must do.
He didn't send Paul to the church to
tell the church what they must do. No,
the other way around.
So, the prophets are in God's church.
A true prophet exalts Christ as the Son
of God, who soever confesseth that Jesus
is the Son of God, God dwelleth in him
and he in God. 1 John 4:15. And
beginning at Moses and all the prophets,
he expounded unto them all in all the
scriptures the things concerning
himself. Luke 24:27. Even Jesus was in
harmony with that.
So, Jesus must be exalted.
Another point. Point five, a true
prophet speaks with authority.
For he taught them as one having
authority and not as one of the scribes.
Matthew 7:29.
Yes, Elijah, John the Baptist, they had
authority. They even rebuked kings.
Number six, a true prophet will bear
good fruit. Wherefore by their fruits
you shall know them. Matthew 7:20.
Interesting point.
And then, there's something that's very
interesting.
A true prophet will exhibit definite
physical signs when in vision.
Now, let's read that.
The prophet's eyes are open during a
vision.
He has said, which heard the words of
God, which saw the vision of the
Almighty, falling
into a trance. The King James versions
has in cursive writing, which means it
is included. It's not in the original
Greek text.
So, falling,
but having his eyes open.
Numbers 24:4.
If you take the New King James, it's a
pretty good translation of the original
text. The utterance of him who hears the
words of God, who sees the vision of the
Almighty, who falls down
with eyes wide open.
So, that's one of the physical
attributes. The prophet falls down
and has the eyes wide open.
Now, if you take the NIV, then you're in
trouble.
The oracle of one who hears the words of
God, who sees the vis- a vision of the
Almighty, who falls prostrate and whose
eyes are opened.
Mhm.
That's not what the original Greek text
says. The Greek text says his eyes are
open.
Here it can be
spiritualized away.
So, again, with the modern translations
based on the Westcott and Hort text, you
cannot use them for doctrinal purposes.
So, let's stick to what the King James
and the New King James says. That's one
of the attributes of a prophet.
Important that we stick to the detail,
the letter of the law.
Second point of this physical attribute
is a true prophet falls down,
has no strength,
is then strengthened,
has no breath even while speaking whilst
in vision. Now, that's a tough act to
follow. That's a very tough act to
follow because only God has life in him
and can give life to his prophet
while he's speaking without breathing.
Let's have a look at it. Daniel 10:7-18.
That's why some very modern Bibles will
remove the whole of Daniel chapter 10.
They don't like it.
And I Daniel alone saw the vision.
There remained no strength in me.
Daniel's strength was taken away.
I kept
no strength.
When I heard the voice of his words,
then I was in a deep sleep on my face.
So, where was he?
Down.
Nor is there breath left in me.
There's no breath in him.
Then again, one like a
man in form came and touched me, and he
made me stronger. There's the sequence.
So, the prophet has no strength, prophet
falls down, prophet has no breath in
him,
and then someone raises him up and he
becomes stronger. How strong does one
tend to become when God touches you with
strength?
Kind of strong.
How strong was Samson when God touched
him?
Well, imagine this. He caught a lion in
midair and pulled him into two pieces.
That's pretty strong.
Can you imagine doing something like
that?
Or he went to the gates of the
Philistine city
and picked up the gates including the
posts that were
attached to it and ripped the whole
foundation out of the floor, lifted it
up, ran up a hill, and plonked it on top
of the hill. Well, that's pretty strong.
Have you any idea how huge those gates
were in the old days? Plus the
foundations and everything that goes
with it.
Pretty strong. Okay.
Just one interesting thing.
So, that's what happens to this prophet
when he goes into vision.
Now, Daniel 10:16, and behold, one in
the likeness of the sons of men touched
my lips,
and I opened my mouth, and I spoke.
In old English, spake. And said unto him
that stood before me, "O my Lord, by
reason of the vision my sorrows are
turned upon me and I retain no strength.
For how can the servant of this my Lord
talk with this my Lord? For as for me,
there remained no strength in me,
neither was there breath left in me."
Interesting. Daniel 10:17. So, he's
speaking to God and he's saying to God,
"How can I speak? I have no breath."
Is this what is happening here?
Okay.
Now, New King James says,
uh Daniel 10:17, "As for me, no strength
remains in me now, nor is any breath
left in me."
When you go to the NIV, you're in
trouble. If you go to the RSV, you're in
trouble.
"My strength is gone and I can hardly
breathe." That's not what the original
says. That is a lie.
That's a blatant lie. I wonder why they
put the blatant lie there. Are they
trying to cover something up?
Cuz their prophets fall down with eyes
closed and they breathe while they are
in vision. Is that a possibility?
Do you think that's a possibility? I
think that's a possibility.
So, what's the summary? The summary is
the prophet falls down weak. Is that
biblical?
Second, he is raised up and strengthened
by God. Is that biblical?
Third, his eyes are wide open during a
vision. Is that biblical?
Fourth, he does not breathe during a
vision but can speak. Is that biblical?
That's what the Bible says.
Now, it sounds highly improbable, but
that's what the Bible says.
Plus all the other points that we
mentioned, all of it must be in harmony.
But this one, as you will imagine, is
one that's a tough act to follow.
Would you agree?
That's a tough act to follow.
Wherefore he says, "When he ascended up
on high, he led captivity captive and
gave gifts unto men." Ephesians 4:8. So,
God gave all the gifts that are needed
into the church. Some apostles, some
prophets, some evangelists, some
pastors, some teachers. Ephesians
Everybody gets a gift.
For the perfecting of the saints. That's
what the gifts are there for.
For the ministry,
taking the message to the outside world,
the edifying of the body of Christ,
Ephesians 4:12. So, these gifts, these
spiritual gifts, are to build up the
church and to empower them to take the
message to a dying world. That's what
they're for.
So, God doesn't give these gifts to
those outside to come and edify his
church. No, his church gets the gifts to
go and edify those outside. Never the
other way around.
Till we all come into the unity of the
faith and of the knowledge of the Son of
God unto a perfect man unto the measure
of the stature of the fullness of
Christ. That's the bottom line.
And through this gift God brings us into
unity as to what is truth and what is
not truth. Now, what if we choose to
reject the prophets of God? What happens
then?
Well, the people of old did it. What did
they do to Isaiah? Did they like his
message?
No, so they took him and they sawed him
in half. It's not a nice thing to do to
a prophet, is it?
Did they like the message of Jeremiah?
No, so they lowered him into a cistern.
They beat him up. They put him into
uh
all kinds of yolks and they really
mistreated him terribly.
Well, they didn't like the messages of
the prophets in the past. Do you think
they'll like the messages of the
prophets
later on? Maybe? You think things will
change or maybe get worse? Who knows?
And God has set some in the church first
apostles, then prophets, then teachers,
then miracles, gifts of healing, helps,
governments, deliverance, tongues, all
kinds of gifts. 1 Corinthians 12:28.
And that we henceforth be no more
children tossed to and fro and carried
about with every wind of doctrine
by the slight of men and the cunning
craftiness whereby they lie in wait to
deceive. Ephesians 4:14.
And then, the early church had wonderful
prophets. They were the most of the
apostles were prophets in their own
right. There were many other prophets as
we will see. And then slowly, the church
changed its rules. And towards the
second century, towards the end, there
was a new form. The disciples retired.
Then the man of sin arose. The horns
were eyes like the eyes of a man
speaking blasphemies, great things,
heathenism, paganism came back into the
church. Shall wear out the saints of the
most high, think to change times and
laws. Now, if God's law no longer exist,
what did the Bible say?
The prophets will no longer find
visions from the Lord. Remember that?
Proverbs 29:18. For there is where there
is no vision, the people perish, but he
that keepeth the law,
happy is he.
The law is no more, her prophets also
find no visions from the Lord.
Lamentations 2:9.
So, prophecies seem to dry up on this
planet.
Seem to dry up.
And then God called the Reformation.
But they didn't rediscover
the law. They didn't come back into
harmony with everything. God led them by
their spirit. You can be led by the
spirit, but that doesn't make you a
prophet. So, they preached great things.
And at the end of time, it shall come to
pass after it that I will pour out my
spirit upon all flesh. Your sons and
daughters shall prophesy. Your young men
shall see vision. The dragon was wroth
with the woman and went to make war with
the remnant of her seed which keep the
commandments of God and have the
testimony of Jesus Christ. At the end of
time,
people will be empowered by the spirit.
So, some will dream things. To dream
something by itself doesn't necessarily
make you a prophet. Some will have
visions.
That's interesting.
And uh
some will be called to the prophetic
ministry. Revelation 12:17.
So, what is this testimony of Jesus?
Remember, we read it. And I fell at his
feet to worship him. And he said to me,
"See that thou do it not. I'm a fellow
servant of thy brethren that have the
testimony of Jesus. Worship God, for
the testimony of Jesus is the spirit of
prophecy." Revelation 19:10.
So, the final church must have the
prophetic gift again, coming behind in
no gift
as they wait for the coming of the Lord.
So, the Bible predicts that the gift of
prophecy will be restored to God's
church in the last days.
Well,
it happened or not? 1 Corinthians 1:6-7.
Even as the testimony of Christ was
confirmed in you so that you come behind
in no gift waiting for the coming of our
Lord Jesus Christ. At the end of time,
when the law will be restored, when the
great biblical truths come to the fore,
then the gift of prophecy will be
restored.
So, God's last day church would keep his
commandments
and have the gift of prophecy. This is a
tough tough situation.
The sun shall be turned to darkness. Do
you remember? Before the great coming of
the day of the Lord, Joel.
And the stars of heaven fell, untimely
figs. We dealt with that when we dealt
with this issue of Revelation chapter
10. William Miller started preaching
about prophecy. Great things were again
discovered. And at the same time as
William Miller starts preaching prophets
prophecy again, here arise a whole host
of prophets.
Wherever you look, there are prophets.
Now, which one is from God
and which one is not from God? That's an
interesting question.
Madam Blavatsky, she says,
"Lucifer is the Logos, the serpent, the
savior. Satan is the only God of this
planet." Does she sound like a true
prophet to you?
I think she doesn't sound like a true
prophet to me because the very first
biblical criteria, she stumbles and
falls and is found wanting.
Because that one says, "To the law and
to the testimony, if they speak not
according to this word, they have no
light in them."
And then it also says that a true
prophet will uplift Jesus Christ
and will acknowledge him as the true Son
of God. This one says Lucifer is the Son
of God. Sorry, Madam Blavatsky,
but you must be a false prophet.
What about Joanna Southcott, mother of
Christ?
1750 to 1814. She said, well, she was
expecting Jesus Christ. She was pregnant
with him. So convinced with her with her
followers that upon her death, they had
an autopsy autopsy done
to find if Jesus wasn't perhaps alive in
her stomach or the Messiah. Well, there
was nothing there.
So, strange.
Did her prophecy come true? No.
What about Russell?
He claimed that he had prophetic
visions.
And what did he do?
He demoted Jesus Christ.
So, must be
false prophet. What about Joseph Smith?
Contradicted the Bible left, right, and
center. Got messages from an angel
Moroni that told him that he was the new
priest and that uh
the true God
was not the one that he claimed to be.
No, no, no. The Mormons claimed the
devil told the truth in Eden. Jehovah
was the liar.
Sorry, Joseph Smith. Sorry, Brigham
Young. You must be false prophets.
You're not speaking according to the
law, neither are you speaking according
to the testimony. And who your angel
Moroni is, I don't know.
Mormon Temple, Salt Lake City.
What about Nostradamus?
Did he speak things that came true?
Well, you can interpret them after the
fact that it might be so because, you
know, his verses sort of
seem to imply that.
Well, if taking drugs is a way to get
prophetic insights, then great. Did he
live the life?
Bear good fruits? I doubt it.
All these millennial prophets. What
about the Gnostic prophets?
They all taught that Jesus was not the
Son of God
and that there was another deity.
What about Edgar Cayce, the great healer
and prophet? Well, he also taught that
we were basically God. What about Pope
Pius?
He said all authority is vested in him.
He also had visions.
And he said that the Roman Catholic
Church would anchor the gospel ship.
Very interesting.
But it wasn't according to the law,
neither according to the testimony. In
fact, they did exactly the opposite.
What about our friend Alister Well, I
wouldn't like to call him a friend.
Alister Crowley
and his all-seeing eye, this great
prophet and magician of the of this New
Age era, the great uh
spokesman for the great rock bands of
the world. Well, one of the most
wow, outspoken critics of the Bible that
the world has ever said seen.
He wanted to be kissed by the wanton
kisses of Babylon. Interesting quotes.
Mariah Devi Christos, Jim Jones, all of
these claimed to be Messiahs. They
turned out to be anything but Messiahs.
So, here in the 1840s, here were all
these false prophets. And there was this
group of Advent believers and a young
man by the name of William Foy, he
received visions.
And then, he refused to speak about
these visions because he said he was
black
and therefore people wouldn't accept him
because of the prejudice of the age.
Then a man by the name of Hazen Foss, he
had visions. And he said, "No,
the consequences are too tough. I'm not
going to repeat this to anyone." So, he
kept it to himself. So, here were young
men having visions, but they refused to
go and speak.
And then a young woman by the name of
Ellen G. Harmon, who later married and
became Ellen G. White, born in 1827,
died in 1915, California, she received
visions.
She was a young girl,
and uh after I had the vision and God
gave me light, he bade me deliver it,
but I shrank from it. I was young and I
thought they would not receive it from
me. That's what she said.
But then one day she decided she would
give statements made by Hazen Foss. Now,
this was the man who previously had a
vision. He refused to give it. Then one
day he decided to try and give it and he
couldn't remember what he'd seen. And
then he attended a meeting where this
young Ellen Harmon was speaking about
what she saw and he said to her, "The
Lord gave me a message to bear to his
people and I refused after being told
the consequences. I heard you talked to
us last night and I believe the visions
are taken from me and given to you. Do
not refuse to obey God for it will be at
the peril of your soul. I am a lost man.
You are chosen of God. Be faithful in
doing your work and the crown I might
have had, you will receive."
Well, that's an interesting story. So,
here is a young girl now with a very
interesting history.
When she was but a young girl,
uh classmate threw a stone at her and
hit her on the head
and she became debilitated
and her front here above the nose was
crushed in and she could not attend more
than 3 years of schooling.
So, this young girl
at the age of 12 was debilitated. Here's
a photograph that's
of her where you can see the one eye is
slightly higher than the other. She was
pretty badly injured,
but of course they in those days they
didn't have the surgery techniques that
they have today.
And this is the young girl that started
following Miller's message together with
many others and then received these
visions and one of them concerned the
sanctuary
and what it stands for. Very fascinating
vision about Christ being the minister
of a sanctuary in heaven which is to be
found in the book of of Hebrews.
Now, remember
that
the dragon was going to be wroth with
the remnant that keeps the commandments
and would have the testimony of Jesus.
He was going to be angry.
So, the final battle, the woman in white
and the dragon and his synagogue,
well, they were going to clash. The
testimony of Jesus, the spirit of
prophecy. So, you become behind in no
gift as you wait for the coming of the
Lord.
And remember 2 Peter which says,
"We have a more sure word of prophecy
where unto you do well that you take
heed as unto a light that shineth in a
dark place until the day dawn and the
day star arise in your hearts. Knowing
this first
that no prophecy of scripture is of any
private interpretation for no prophecy
ever came by the will of man, but men
spoke from God being moved by the Holy
Spirit." So, the question is,
is this from God or is it from the
devil?
Test the prophets, the Bible says.
Not all prophets contributed to the
scriptures. One argument would be, but
did this person contribute anything to
the scriptures? Answer is no.
God used both men and women as a prophet
because this was a female.
Examples in the Old Testament, Nathan
and Gad, 2 Samuel
and 1 Samuel,
they didn't contribute to the
scriptures. Prophetesses included
Miriam, Exodus 15:20, Huldah the
prophetess, 2 Kings 22:14, and Deborah,
Judges 4:4.
Examples in the New Testament of
prophets and prophetesses that didn't
take up weren't taken up in the canon
include Simeon, Anna, Agabus, Barnabas,
Philip's four daughters. These were all
prophets in the Bible
that didn't contribute to the Bible. So,
the vital question,
did she fulfill the biblical criteria?
It's a very interesting question that I
would like to know.
Well, manuscripts 88 1900, "The Lord has
said, Write out the things which I shall
give you
and I commenced when I was very young to
do this work. My hand that was feeble
and trembling because of infirmities
became steady as soon as I took the pen
in my hand and since those first
writings I've been able to write." She
was only 17 years old, had only 3 years
of schooling and started to write.
So, one argument that people had,
can God use someone that is so
physically weak and only has 3 years of
schooling?
Well, yes. In fact, God can use a
donkey.
Didn't he use a donkey?
Yes, he used a donkey.
And what happens if you refuse to listen
to the donkey?
Well, then you could just die.
You see? So, if he could use a donkey,
then surely he could use someone with 3
years of education. That's better than a
donkey. I don't recall donkeys going to
school, do you?
So, anyway, she says,
"Soon as I took a pen in my hand and
since those first writings I've been
able to write."
So, now let's look at the criteria. Did
she exalt the word of God and the law of
God?
The Bible.
What did she write? Selected Messages
Volume 2, "The Holy Scriptures are to be
accepted as an authoritative, infallible
revelation of his will.
They are to be the standard of
character, the revealer of doctrine, and
the test of experience."
Bible.
"Cling to your Bible as it reads and
stop your criticism in regard to its
validity and obey the word of God and
not one of you will be lost." Selected
Messages Volume 1, page 18.
And now, what is supposed to be the
creed? Selected Messages Volume 1, page
416, "The Bible and the Bible alone is
to be our creed. The sole bond of union.
God's word is infallible. Lift up the
banner on which is inscribed The Bible,
our rule of faith and discipline."
Question.
If she wrote so much and the Bible is to
be our only creed, then why bother to
write so much?
Isn't the Bible enough?
Well, aren't the people confusing the
Bible today everywhere, left, right, and
center?
So,
she cannot add anything. She cannot
subtract anything. She can just write
put light upon what there is already
present. That's all that she could do
because she clearly says,
"The Bible and the Bible alone is to be
our creed."
So, if somebody comes and says, "Aha,
but here it says that you must do this,
that, and the other." I say, "Where do
you get that from? Show it to me in the
Bible. If it's not there, goodbye."
That's what she says. Five testimonies,
"The Lord designs to warn you, to
reprove, to counsel through the
testimonies given, and to impress your
minds with the importance of the truths
of his word. So, that's what it's for.
The written testimonies are not to give
new light,
but to impress vividly upon the heart
the truths of inspiration already
revealed. That's what the prophets did
all along.
Man's duty to God and to his fellow man
has been distinctly specified in God's
word, yet but few of you are obedient to
the light given. Additional truth is not
brought out,
but God has through the testimonies
simplified the great truths already
given and in his own chosen way brought
them before the people to awaken and
impress the mind with them that all may
be left without excuse."
So, here is something that seems to be
in law and harmony with the law and the
Bible.
Five 15 manuscripts released, then
present them the prophecies.
Show them the purity and binding claims
of the law of God. Not one jot or tittle
of this law is to lose its force, but
hold its binding claims upon every soul
to the end of time. Is that in harmony
with the law and the and the testimony?
Yeah.
Cannot men see that to belittle the law
of God is to dishonor Christ? Why did he
come to this world to suffer and die if
the law is not binding upon human
beings? That makes sense.
Call to expose the man of sin.
In the very time in which we live, the
Lord has called his people and has given
them a message to bear. Has called them
to expose the wickedness of the man of
sin who has made the Sunday law
distinctive power, who has sought to
change times and laws and to oppress the
people of God who stand firmly to honor
him by keeping the only true Sabbath,
the Sabbath of creation, as holy unto
the Lord.
Definitely in harmony with the
scriptures, maybe not in harmony with
the feelings of many organizations in
the world,
but it's biblical.
Did her predictions come true?
Well, that's an interesting point.
San Francisco earthquake, April 18,
1906, she predicted it. Yes, it came
true.
She predicted great turmoil and wars.
The Lord declares through the prophet
Isaiah,
"Associate yourselves, oh you people,
and you shall be broken in pieces. And
give ear, all ye far countries. Gird
yourselves and you shall be broken in
pieces." This is a quote direct from
Isaiah 8:9-3.
"Gird yourselves and you be broken in
pieces. Take counsel together and it
shall come to naught. Speak the word and
it shall not stand for God is with us.
For the Lord spoke thus to me with a
strong hand and instructed me that I
should not walk in the way of this
people saying, A confederacy to all them
to whom the people shall say, "A
confederacy. Neither fear ye their fear,
nor be afraid. Sanctify the Lord of
hosts himself, and let him be your fear,
and let him be your dread."
Now, here's an interesting scripture.
What does it mean? You can have a
thousand interpretations. Here's an
interesting one.
She writes, "There are those who
question whether it is right for
Christians to belong to Freemasons and
other secret societies."
"Let all such consider the scriptures
just quoted."
"If we are Christians at all, we must be
Christians everywhere, and must consider
and heed the counsel given to make us
Christians according to the standard of
God's word." Ooh, interesting statement.
"This terrible picture drawn by John,
the Revelation, shows how completely the
powers of earth will give themselves
over to evil,
and should show those who have received
the truth how dangerous it is to link up
with secret societies, or to join
themselves in any way to those who do
not keep God's commandments."
Fascinating stuff. 40 manuscript
release.
"By a variety of images, the Lord Jesus
presented to John the wicked character
and the seductive influence of those who
have been distinguished for their
persecution of God's people."
This starts to make Revelation come
alive. There's nothing new here. It
stands in the book of Revelation.
"God's presentation of the detestable
works of the inhabitants of the ruling
powers of the world will bind themselves
into secret societies, confederacies not
honoring the law of God." "Keep clear of
these evils. More and more false
religionists of the world manifest their
evil doings."
"There are but two parties."
"Those who keep the commandments of God,
and those who war against
God's law."
Very interesting. And so, she continues
here with a host of quotes
dealing with this very issue. 4
manuscripts release is fascinating.
"In the world, gigantic monopolies will
be formed." Now, remember this is
written 150 years ago.
Do we find today gigantic monopolies
being formed?
Absolutely. Everywhere.
"Men will bind themselves together in
unions that will wrap them in the folds
of the enemy. A few men will combine to
grasp all the means to be obtained in a
certain line of business." Is that
happening today?
Do we have mega stores, mega banks, mega
this, mega that? Yes or no?
Absolutely. "Trade unions will be
formed." Will be formed. Take note.
"And those who refuse to join these
unions will be marked men." Is that
happening today? Yes or no?
Absolutely. I've stood on the other side
of trade unions gone berserk.
It's scary. Let me tell you. It's scary.
"The trade unions will be one of the
agencies that will bring about upon this
earth a time of trouble such as not been
since the world began." Can you imagine
the turmoil that happens when labor
unrest comes to a country? Unbelievable.
I can tell you stories about this.
Unbelievable. 150 years ahead of time.
What does the world teach? It's a human
right to have all of these. It's a human
right. "In the revelation of his
righteous judgments, God will break up
all these associations."
"And the judgment shall sit, the books
will be opened, and the
un-Christ-likeness of the whole
confederacy will be plain to other. They
serve gods as useless to save as the
gods of the Hindus."
Interesting.
"The message we bear must be as direct
as the message of John, who rebuked
kings for their iniquity."
Fascinating stuff. "We do not go in deep
enough in our search for truth. Every
soul who believes present truth will be
brought where he will be required to
give a reason for the hope that is in
him. The people of God will be called
upon to stand before kings, princes,
rulers, great men of the earth, and they
must know that they do know what is
truth."
"They must be converted men and women.
God can teach you more in one moment by
his Holy Spirit than you could learn
from the great men of the earth. The
universe is looking upon the controversy
that is going on upon the earth."
It's very Christ-centered. It's
Bible-centered.
And this is happening all over the
world.
"Those who stand under the blood-stained
banner of Prince Emmanuel cannot be
united with Freemasons or secret
organizations."
"Either you are with Christ, or you are
against him."
"At an infinite cost, God has provided
for every man an opportunity to know
that which will make him wise unto
salvation." "How eagerly do angels look
to see what will avail himself of this
opportunity."
"When a message is presented to God's
people, they should not rise up in
opposition to it. They should go to the
Bible, comparing it with the law and the
testimony. And if it does not bear this
test, it is not true."
"God wants our minds to expand. He
desires to put his grace upon us. We may
have a feast of good things every day,
for God can open a whole treasure of
heaven to us." Does this sound biblical?
I think it does.
"The judgments of earth are abroad.
Floods, tempests, wrath will be poured
out, etc." Interesting stations. "Nation
will be on the side of the rebel
nation."
And then, you have these great events
of
our time.
The Twin Towers. 1904,
in a manuscript she writes, "When I was
last in New York, I was in the night
season called upon to behold buildings
rising story after story towards
heaven." That's before New York had
high-rise buildings.
"These buildings were warranted to be
fireproof, and they were erected to
glorify the owners. Higher and still
higher these buildings rose, and in them
the most costly material was used. The
scene that next passed was an alarm of
fire. Men looked at lofty and supposedly
fireproof buildings, and said they are
perfectly safe. But these buildings were
consumed as if made of pitch. The fire
engines could nothing do nothing to stay
the destruction."
She says, "I awoke, and from my window I
saw a terrible conflagration. Great
balls of fire were falling upon houses,
and from these balls, fiery arrows were
flying in every direction." If you watch
television, you will have seen this
vision in detail.
"It was impossible to check the files.
Many places was being destroyed. The
terror of the people was indescribable."
"While appearing to the children of men
as a great physician to heal their
maladies maladies,
he will bring disease and disaster." And
then, she goes on to explain.
And she uses the text, "The earth
mourneth and fadeth away. The haughty
people do languish. The earth also is
defiled under the inhabitants thereof,
because they have transgressed the laws,
changed the ordinances, broken the
everlasting covenant." Isaiah 24:4 and
5. She used the Bible for every single
thing.
"To the law and to the testimony,
if they keep not according to this word,
they have no light in them."
Now, there's one other thing that is
very interesting that Ellen White saw.
And that is the great health vision.
This is an amazing vision that really
fascinated me.
Now, as a scientist, and as a
physiologist,
this was something that stunned me. In
1864, she wrote, "Tobacco is a poison of
the most deceitful and malignant kind,
having an exciting and then a paralyzing
influence upon the nerves of the body.
It is all the more dangerous because its
effect upon the system are so slow,
and at first scarcely perceivable.
Multitudes have fallen victim to its
poisonous influence."
Well, that's no big deal. Everybody
knows cigarettes are bad for you.
But this was written in 1864,
when the medical world was teaching that
this was the new cure to all lung
ailments.
And when the when medical world was
saying, "Smoke, and this will help you,
and it'll get rid of all your problems,
all your maladies." Here comes one
little woman and writes exactly the
opposite to what the world was teaching.
It was not until 1957
that a committee of scientists appointed
by the American Cancer Society and the
American Heart Association concluded
that smoking was a causative factor in
lung cancer.
So, she is way ahead of her time, no
doubt. What did she write about tea and
coffee?
What did she write about the lifestyles
that people have in the world today?
What did she write about foods high in
cholesterol and all of these things?
Today, we have fear fear in the food
chain, toxins. We have encephalitis
diseases. We have diseases amongst
animals as you cannot imagine. I made
this part of my research at the
university, and I received awards for
the research that we were doing.
And I even received from
um
from London,
I received an award to do research in
this particular field from the Royal
Society of London. I was one of only
five scientists to receive this. We did
so many tests on transfer of diseases
from animals to man,
and amazing things that we discovered.
Health alert over chickens.
"Deadly eggs," says Der Spiegel.
Ellen White wrote in 1901, "Soon butter
will never be recommended." Has it come
to pass?
Absolutely. And after a time, milk will
be entirely discarded for disease in
animals is increasing proportion to the
increase of wickedness among men. The
time will come when there will be no
safety in using eggs, milk, cream, or
butter. Deadly eggs.
Incredible. She saw a deterioration in
the animal world. "Flesh was never the
best food, but it is now doubly
objectionable since disease in animals
is so rapidly increasing." And she talks
about milk that it should be thoroughly
sterilized. With this precaution,
there's less danger of contracting
disease. Way ahead of her time. "Butter
is less harmful when eaten on cold bread
than when used in cooking." Now, hold
on.
How did she know that?
You see, how could she know that when
butter is heated, it forms free radicals
which are carcinogenic number one and
which cause clogging of the arteries?
Nobody knew that in her day.
This was way ahead of time. So, very
simple. You take butter and you do the
tests and you'll find out what happens,
and you'll see this is correct.
This is correct. "But as a rule, it is
better to dispense with it altogether."
Way ahead of her time. "Cheese is still
more objectionable. It's wholly unfit
for food." Wow, you say that loud. I
have a whole lecture on this
that I give in scientific circles, and
there's no two ways about this one. It's
one of the most allergenic foods in the
world. Asthma would probably disappear.
Osteoporosis would probably disappear
from the face of the earth if people
would take heed to these these
suggestions. "Cheese should never be
introduced into the stomach." Which
countries have the highest rate of
osteoporosis in the world?
The Netherlands, Norway, all the dairy
countries. They have the highest rate of
osteoporosis. Why? Because they're
eating the food with the highest
acid-forming content in the world, which
has to be neutralized by calcium release
from the bone and causes osteoporosis.
We could save ourselves a lot of trouble
here.
"Let the diet reform be progressive. Let
people be taught how to prepare food
without the use of milk or butter. Let
them Let the time will soon come when
there will be no safety in using eggs,
milk, cream, or butter because disease
in animals is increasing creasing in
proportion to the wickedness of men."
Very interesting. The killers all
around. That's what science is saying.
"In all parts of the world, provision
will be made to supply the place of milk
and eggs." Has it happened?
Yesterday, you get rice milk, soy milk,
oat milk, you name it. Nut milk. "And
the Lord will let us know when the time
comes to give up these He desires all to
feel that we have a gracious heavenly
Father who will instruct them in all
things. And the Lord will give dietetic
art and skill to his people in all parts
of the world, teaching them how to use
for the sustenance of life the products
of the earth." Wonderful regard. Now,
regard to milk and sugar.
"I know of persons who have become
frightened of health reform and said
would have nothing to do with it because
it is spoken against the free use of
these things. Changes should be made
with great care. We should move
cautiously and wisely. There's no
fanaticism here." "We want to take the
course that will recommend itself to the
intelligent men and women of the land.
Large quantities of milk and sugar eaten
together are injurious and impart
impurities to the system. Sugar clogs
the system and hinders the working of
the living machine."
This must be rubbish, right?
Unless you go and test it. What's the
problem with milk and sugar? What's the
problem there with?
Well, a scientist came to my university
and he had a lecture to give to the
physiology department. I'm a I was
totally secular university.
And he said, "I did research on the
combination of milk and sugar for a
chocolate company." Because that's what
chocolate is. It's the combination of
milk and sugar, right?
And he said, "What I found is so
hair-raising, I'll never be funded again
by a chocolate company.
Number one, if I took the milk by
itself, the triglycerides went up, the
cholesterol went up, and the sugar went
up in the blood and came down after 3
hours. If I take the sugar by itself, I
was surprised to see the triglycerides
go up. I saw the cholesterol levels go
up and the sugar go up and then end in
hypoglycemia. That was bad. But when I
combined them, it was a total nightmare.
Because not only did they rise more than
double, but it stayed like that for 10
hours. So, the best recipe for dying in
your sleep is to take a milk and sugar
combination just before you go to sleep
because it'll slow down your blood sugar
clogs the system to such an extent that
you could die. And most people actually
die in their sleep of heart attacks. And
that's the favorite drink. Before you go
to sleep, you take milk and sugar
because it switches off the brain, and
then you go to sleep."
Well, she said that 150 years ago. Isn't
that surprising?
What wonderful things. Someone may
attempt to explain how she said all
these things. How did she quote from the
current literature? Well, how would she
know what to quote?
Ministry of Healing, Temperance,
Councils on Diets and Food. There is a
host of stuff in there. Did she edify
the church?
Did she do that?
"I said that I did not claim to be a
prophetess. I have not stood before the
people claiming this title, though many
many called me thus. I've been
instructed to say I'm God's messenger
sent to bear a message of reproof." So,
some said, "Okay, she says she's not a
prophetess."
"To claim to be a prophetess is
something I have never done. If others
call me by that name, I have no
controversy with them." So, they put
pressure on her. Are you a prophet or
you not a prophet? She says, "You know,
there are so many false prophets out.
Why should I say I'm a prophet? I'm a
prophet." She was humble about it.
"I cannot call myself other than a
messenger sent to bear a message from
the Lord to his people and to take up a
work in any line that he points out."
Well, "during the discourse, I said that
I did not claim to be a prophetess. Some
were surprised at the statement, and as
much as being said in regard to it, I
will make an explanation." "Others have
called me a prophetess, but I have never
assumed this title. I have not felt that
it was my duty to thus designate
myself."
"Those who boldly assume that they are
prophets in this day are often a
reproach to the cause of Christ. My work
includes
much more than this name signifies. I
regard myself as a messenger entrusted
by the Lord with messages for his
people."
"I am now instructed that I am not to be
hindered in my work by those who engage
in suppositions regarding its nature as
minds are struggling with so many
issues."
"My commission embraces the work of a
prophet, but it does not end there." So,
she said she was a prophet. She said she
was a prophet.
Did she exalt Christ as the Son of God?
There's a beautiful statement in the
Review and Herald.
"The world's Redeemer was treated as we
deserve to be treated in order that we
might be treated as he deserved to be
treated. He came to our world and took
our sins upon his divine soul that we
might receive his imputed righteousness.
He was condemned for our sins in which
he had no share that we might be
justified by his righteousness in which
we had no share."
I wish I had only 3 years of education
and could write like that.
The Desire of Ages, probably one of the
greatest books ever written. Now, I'll
qualify that. I believe it is the
greatest book ever written on the life
of Jesus Christ. Anybody who reads that
will be stunned. Her writings, only one
other woman compares.
And that woman's name is Alice A.
Bailey.
She exalts Lucifer and says, "I have no
other task but to prepare the world for
the coming of the coming one," who is
Lucifer.
And this one over here says no other
life task but to prepare the way for the
coming of Jesus Christ, the one in the
Bible.
To the law and to the testimony.
Christ's Object Lessons, The Desire of
Ages, Steps to Christ, Thoughts from the
Mount of Blessing.
Wow, there are so many books dealing
with Jesus Christ. It's unbelievable.
All painfully written by hand.
Manuscript of the manuscript. Did she
speak with authority?
"I am instructed to say that those who
endeavor to tear down the foundations of
what made us Seventh-day Adventists, we
are God's commandment-keeping people.
For the past 50 years, every phase of
heresy has been brought to bear upon us
to becloud our mind regarding the
teachings of the word. He calls upon us
to hold firmly with a grip of faith to
the fundamental principles that are
based on unquestionable
authority." Did she bear good fruit?
Well, wherever she went today, there are
hospitals, there are teaching
institutions.
Everywhere,
the work has been
built up. This was where she lived when
she died, Elmshaven.
And uh
simple table. That's where she wrote
most of her visions. This is one of her
great great-granddaughters, Gladys
Kubrock. And uh she still talks about
some of the things that she remembers.
Did she exhibit the physical signs? Now,
here is the crux of the matter. You see,
the prophet has to fulfill all the
signs. Does she qualify?
Let me summarize them for you once
again. Number one,
the prophet falls down weak. We got this
from the Bible and the Bible alone,
remember?
Number two, raised up and strengthened
by God. Number three, eyes were open
during a vision. Number four,
does not breathe during a vision, but
can speak. Tough act to follow.
Now, these were camp camp meetings. Now,
normally,
prophets go into vision in some secluded
little room with a bunch of people
around them all convinced or whatever.
Not this one.
Ellen White went into visions publicly
with thousands of people and skeptics
all around.
And publicly, in front of all those
people,
God gave her visions.
Later on in life, when this was no
longer necessary, most of her visions
were in dreams. But when she started
off, the visions were public visions.
And what happened at those visions?
Well, here are the writings. In passing
into vision, she gives three enraptured
shouts of glory which echo and re-echo.
Then, for about four or five seconds,
she seems to drop down like a person in
a swoon or one having lost his strength.
She then seems to be instantly filled
with superhuman strength,
sometimes rising at once to her feet,
walking about the room or in the camp
meeting or in the gathering or wherever
she was.
Her eyes are always open, but she does
not wink. Her hand is raised and she
looks upward, not with a vacant stare,
but with a pleasant expression.
Eyewitness account, June 12, 1868. She
walked back and forth and talked to us,
and as she walked, she fell right down.
Prophet falls down.
She fell down gently. There was no
catcher behind her.
She went down as an angel's hands was
under her. Sister White lay perfectly
quiet and unconscious. Her eyes were
open with a pleasant expression on her
face. Nothing unnatural or unusual.
Brother White, that was her husband,
said to these large men,
"Take her hands apart." There she was
lying. "Take her hands apart. You have
two hands to her one. Just pull her
hands apart." There was this frail
little girl lying there. So, they tried.
They pulled and pulled till some of us
got anxious that they would hurt her.
It's a public vision.
Brother White said, "Don't be anxious.
She is safe in God's keeping. You can
pull until you are perfectly satisfied."
They said, "We are satisfied.
Now, we don't need to pull anymore." He
said, "Take up one finger at a time."
This was impossible.
They could not so much as move a finger.
It seemed like a block of granite.
Brother White said to these men, "Now,
hold her." When she got up and she
started speaking and moving her hands
and speaking about whatever she saw,
I think they thought they could. They
grasped her by the wrists, but they
could not the motion. So, these
big men,
when she went like this, they went
along, whether they liked it or not.
It looked like any child could hold her,
but she went on just the same.
Now, we must see if her eyelids were
closed. There was a large Rochester lamp
close by. Remove the shade, put the
light right in front of her eyes. We
thought she would move her eyes to
protect them. She didn't. She was
perfectly unconscious. The eyelids did
not close.
Brother White said, "We must see if
there's any breath in her body." There
didn't seem to be any.
Everything looked all right. Only there
was no breath. Brother White said, "Now,
we will send out and get a mirror and we
will test it."
So, someone went to the next door and
got a mirror. It was held close to her
face, but no moisture gathered, so there
was no breathing.
All right.
Then she went into vision again, and
medical doctors, skeptics came to test.
Two physicians came in, an old man and a
young man.
Brother White was anxious that they
should examine Sister White closely,
which they did. A looking glass was
brought. One of them held it to her
mouth while she talked, but very soon
they gave this up and said she doesn't
breathe.
They
then closely examined her sides as she
spoke to find some evidence of deep
breathing, but they did not find it. As
they closed this part of the
examination, she arose to her feet still
in vision, holding a Bible high up,
turning from page to passage, quoting
correctly, although the eyes were
looking upward and away from the Bible.
So, she held the Bible up like this and
paged like this, quoting from the Bible.
So, somebody must have gotten up on a
chair and checked it out. And yes, it
was right.
And here this little girl was holding
this huge family Bible for hours on end
while she was speaking and not
breathing.
After Mrs. White rose to her feet, as
they have stated, quoting the texts of
scripture, Dr. Fleming called for a
lighted candle. He held this candle as
near to her lips as possible without
burning and in direct line with her
breath in case she breathed. There was
not the slightest flicker of the blaze.
The doctor then said with emphasis,
"That settles it forever. There's no
breath in her
body."
Either this is true or it's not true.
These are public
public meetings.
The gift of prophecy, 1844 to 1950.
Either it is from God
or it is not from God.
Well, today,
this prophet sleeps.
This prophet
is no longer there, but the writings
linger.
She showed no spiritual pride.
She sought no filthy lucre.
She lived the life and did the work of a
worthy prophetess, the most admirable of
the American succession. This is the New
York Independent, August 23, 1925. A
totally independent source.
So, now we have this choice.
Do you know what happened to me?
When I began to discover the truths of
the Bible,
I said, "The Bible and the Bible alone.
I don't need this stuff.
I don't need this.
Give me the Bible. It does everything
for me. I don't need anything else."
And then I got a phone call
from a colleague of mine
who had heard
that I had become an Adventist.
At first, he gave me blazes for having
become an Adventist.
And then he went to town
on this woman.
I'd never read a word of hers. I'd
become an Adventist on the Bible and the
Bible alone. Nothing to do with the
spirit of prophecy.
And then he went to town. And he called
her the most
terrible things that you can imagine.
He was so irate about this, and the
words that came out of his mouth,
I don't even want to repeat them.
And when he put the phone down, I
thought to myself, "Now, who is this
that someone should be so angry about
these writings?"
So, I went and found them and started
reading.
And the more I read,
and I couldn't read without my Bible
next to me.
And my Bible started coming alive.
And for the first time, I understood
Jesus Christ and what he meant for me.
And I could have found it in the Bible,
but I couldn't find it in that depth
that I found it explained in the spirit
of prophecy. The Bible became alive. She
didn't take me away from the Bible. She
led me to the Bible.
And so, this prophet
that is demeaned in the world, that is
detested in the world,
if anybody hears even the name, they
will say the most horrendous things
about this prophet.
A liar, a plagiarist, the this, the
that, and the other. You name it.
Test the prophets.
Now,
isn't it so that when the prophet is
loved and revered in the world,
that there's probably a problem with it?
Why is Alice A. Bailey honored at the
level of the United Nations? Why are her
writings the basis of the world core
curriculum?
Why does
this prophetess influence the world so
much
and this one
is so despised?
Interesting question.
So, my answer to you is,
if it is from God,
then accept it and read it.
And if you find that it takes you away
from the Bible, throw it aside
and read the Bible and the Bible alone.
Because after all, she does say, "We
have no other creed except the Bible."
So, the proof of the pudding is in the
eating. But every single biblical
criterion is fulfilled by her.
And I know of no other prophet of modern
times that qualifies. Not one.
>> Mhm.